Next, we're going to take a look at some of the settings you can update that will affect
the handling of your vehicle.
We'll look at what happens when you tweak the value of the center of mass inside the
vehicle blueprint, and then how we can tweak some of the settings inside the wheel blueprints
themselves to fine-tune the cornering of the vehicle.
So to tweak the center of mass, if you open up your vehicle blueprint and select
the vehicle movement component, just kind of search for center of mass here, and we'll
enable the center of mass override so that we can set some manual values.
And you know, you can move the center of mass forwards and backwards, up and down,
left or right, depending on what values you put in these axes.
So to move it forwards and backwards, we could do that with the X axis here.
So let's say we move it backwards 50 units and see how that affects our vehicle's handling.
So you can see as I turn now when we've got some sort of speed up with our acceleration,
the back end flies out because a lot of the mass is no longer over the center of
the vehicle.
It's quite far back.
And we can come back here and tweak those values and do the same for Y, for example.
So let's say 100 in Y and put it right the way off to the side.
You can see that already that's quite a detrimental effect on our vehicle, but you could see
how that's quite a useful thing for maybe you wanted to update that runtime and change
the values on your vehicle, depending on what sort of scenario you're in.
And if we were to update it in Z, for example, so if we go 200 units above the floor,
this might be a bit too much, it's time to freak out a little bit, but you can see
how that really makes your vehicle quite unstable.
Also, you have to be fairly conservative with these depending on what kind of feeling you
want to get out of your vehicle.
Some other settings we can change are inside the wheel blueprints themselves.
So if we just open both of those up, two things that we could tweak to adjust the
sort of feeling of the handling are the cornering stiffness and the friction force
multiplier.
So with the rear wheels, for example, if we were to bring the cornering stiffness
down to a quarter of what it was, and then hit play, you'll see that that gives us the
back end sliding out just a little bit, as we lose some of that friction and some of
that grip that we had on it, we can see that immediately gives you quite a different
feel to your vehicle, and allows you to kind of tweak it and get some get some cool
feeling results quite quickly.
If we were to do that with the front wheels as well, we could do something like, well,
if we go, if we were to go the opposite direction, like increase the friction on
both of these wheels, we put that back up to 1000, maybe this to four as well,
you'll see that the vehicle sticks to the road quite well, and doesn't let the
back end or front end fly out at all.
Even when we go at full speed, and I hit sort of A or D to turn left or right,
we're sticking to the road really, really nicely.
And that's just because we're increasing that friction, and we're increasing the
stiffness for the cornering.
And inside both of these blueprints, there are lots and lots of different
settings you can tweak here for adjusting how the vehicle feels.
So you've got the obviously the wheels here that we've got access to stuff like
friction and cornering stiffness, as well as suspension settings that are just how
your the body of your car is reacting to the road that your vehicle is on,
as well as inside the vehicle movement component of your vehicle's blueprint.
So tweaking things like your engine, any sort of torque control setups and
things like that you can do in here.
So there is a lot of different options that you can kind of tweak and adjust to
get your car feeling just how you want it to.
But the general advice, but the general advice would be to just kind of
tweak one thing at a time, and then test it out to see how that's affecting
the handling of your vehicle.
And slowly just keep going like that until you get the handling that you're after.